je vous ai parlé d'un casque je vous ai
parlé d'un casque à réduction de bruit
de la société divac en nomade nomades
plus je vais tester d'ici quelques jours
mais avant je vous parlais d'un autre
casque d'or note castet réduction de
bruit qui est peut-être le meilleur
casque car ils font du bruit du marché
je n'avance pas trop je vais tester
d'ici quelques temps le temps qu'il
arrive tranquillement au studio c'est le
casque de sony bougeait toujours un
petit peu mal à dire non c'est le whh
1000 x m3 alors si vous arrivez à me
lire
voilà c'est écrit là je sais j'écris
très mal ce que je vous propose c'est de
vous ramener à berlin on va en parler
avec un des hauts responsables de chez
sony qui nous parle justement de ce
casque qu'il est ce qu'on peut faire
avec les évolutions à lanfains petit
brief et puis d'ici quelques jours
j'ai bien envie de parler d'autres
jouent en ce moment un sujet qui
m'intéresse vachement je vais vous
présenter notre casque de sony j'ai reçu
celui là alors tant qu'à ce qui est déjà
sorti à quelques temps mais qui est
cadet plutôt cool c'est le mw tirer w s
623 sony pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
des noms aussi compliqué pour vos
casques pourquoi vous pourriez pas
l'appeler le casque je sais pas beaucoup
mais leur dédie non un peu sympa du coup
les références sont hyper compliqué à
tenir alors pour du professionnel je
comprends mais pour du grand public moi
je trouve ça super super dur alors merci
de m'avoir mis un joli petit mot je vous
lis je partage avec vous et l'aurait
lien voici le sony n est pas tiré
w 623 bon test l'équipe sony merci
beaucoup sony je vais tester un grand
plaisir
puis vous fera un test à vous qui
regardez un retour en tout cas sur ce
produit
on va assister l'audio en vous avions
fait beaucoup de smartphones des
ordinateurs des tablettes
on s'intéresse à pas mal de choses et
puis l'audio chance à ypres à coup j'ai
aussi d'autres casques de côté là qu'on
va regarder d'ici quelques temps donc on
va concentrer là dessus donc tout ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on retombe à berlin
comme ça au moins on va parler
tranquillement du
w à chenilles l'x l'appel 3
[Musique]
j
ok
[Musique]
c'est notre gros lancement en casque
effectivement sur l'instinct si la
troisième génération de ce produit c'est
notre meilleur produit en termes de
casques bluetooth à réduction de bruit
pourquoi les gens se tournent de plus en
plus vers le bluetooth la réunion oui
tout simplement parce que vous avez le
confort du bluetooth vous n'avez pas de
câble qui va entre votre votre
smartphone et votre casque mais ensuite
la réduction de bruit s'est pas fait que
pour l'homme d'affaires qui fait à paris
tokyo 12 heures
c'est aussi tous les jours je me balade
dans la rue
je veux pas encore la circulation ou
simplement j'ai un quart d'heure vingt
minutes 30 minutes de métro le matin
peut pas entendre les roms ou les gens
qui sont avec moi je veux juste
simplement pouvoir visionner dans la
musique éléments termes de santé ça
évite de pousser le sont beaucoup trop
fort absolument de perdre de l'audition
et ça c'est absolument c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on à l'efficacité d'une très
bonne réduction de bruit on n'est pas
obligé du tout de d'écouté port pour
apprécier sa musique puisque vous n'avez
que votre musique
ouais ça c'est vraiment génial et le mar
3 apporte plein d'améliorations par
rapport aux générations précédentes
d'accord
évidemment on avait déjà dans les
produits marque un mark ii on avait déjà
beaucoup de
deux tests extrêmement positive qui nous
donnait comme quoi on était la meilleure
réduction de du marché là on va aller
encore plus loin puisqu'on à améliorer
notamment la réduction des voix
et dans la cascade réduction de bruit
dans la technologie des actions risquées
entre guillemets et facile c'est de
réduire un bruit constant genre dans la
cabine d'un avion
un trafic constant ce qui est beaucoup
plus difficile c'est les voix parce que
les voix mais on n'a pas la même
intonation on n'a pas la victoire sa
fausse afrique énormément et du coup il
faut que le casque soit capable de
calculer très rapidement
les
l'ailé
les niveaux de son qu'il doit annuler
dans le cadre de la réduction tout est
d'accord et donc ça c'est possible avec
une nouvelle puce qu'on a appelé la cu
est un qui est intégrée dans cette
nouvelle génération c'est pour ça qu on
a une réduction cui encore meilleur que
les produits précédents d'accord ok
après en terme de confort très générales
d'utilisation on a fait plein
d'améliorations
très notable d'une part il est hyper
léger donc quand on a une une écoute
prolongée un vol justement un peu long
et ça pèse moins sur les oreilles sur la
tête c'est très agréable
ensuite on est passé sur un mode de
recharge en usb c'est la cas permet
notamment d'avoir un mode de recharge
rapide
dix minutes je vais pouvoir partir pour
cinq heures de musique dis donc je pars
j'ai joué à marseille pour le week-end
j'ai trois heures de tgv ouvrir de
recharge est monté dans mon casque
pas de problème dix minutes j'ai bien
varié j'ai mon quasiment dans aller
retour de d'assurer ensuite toujours en
termes de de confort et d'utilisation je
vais pouvoir le configurer de façon à ce
que le pavé tactile puisse lancer
directement le google assistante on a
pavé tactile qui on a un pavé tactile
qui permet de contrôler la musique
d'augmenter le son de passer à la
prochaine musique de faire cause tout
simplement et je vais pouvoir le
configurer pour que ça soit aussi un
bouton de lancer lancement du google à 6
tonnes
ok
qu'est-ce que j'oublie en termes de
confort d'utilisation
trente huit heures d'autonomie d'accord
là
on a vraiment le temps de voir veut dire
quoi ça et
le poids on va parler la réduction de
bruit
voilà notre meilleur casque en bluetooth
est en réduction d'accord ok bon vin
génial c'est disponible en magasin à
partir la semaine prochaine ok à 380
euros
380 disponible en deux couleurs en black
et platinum silver hockey sont bien
jolies c'est très joli et en plus on a
fait un vrai effort pour une finition
bijoux
aussi bien sur les micro de réduction de
bruit que sur le logo
on est maintenant avec
champagne
très très très très riche
[Musique]
mais je
le deuxième cas ce que vous voyez dans
la vidéo c'est autre chose on n'est pas
du tout sur le même produit
on est vraiment sûr de l'ecoute comment
vous dire c'est un amplificateur un peu
à j'ai mangé le nom c'est un
amplificateur un peu old school pas si
c'est vraiment le théâtre on a une
restitution du son qui est juste
incroyable vous écouter du jazz là
dedans que c'est une fermez les yeux
vous y êtes vous êtes dans la salle
c'est le son est complètement officines
donc je voulais vous montrer quelques
images pour ça n'a rien à voir est sûre
avec le whh 1000 x m3 comme attesté et
d'ici quelques jours donc vous invite à
vous abonner à rester connectés puis
dites moi parce que ce produit déjà sur
le marché est ce que vous l'avez acheté
est ce qui vous intéresse
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous intéresser
et s'il vous intéresse et que vous
l'avez pas encore en tout cas je vous ai
mis un lien en bas d'un disque et on est
je vous dis j'ai vachement vous parler
de dieu parce que je trouve ça vraiment
cool vraiment intéressant moi mon nez
premier job j'étais technicien sont donc
je sonorisé des groupes façade retour
pour fadi donc l'audio c'est vraiment ce
qui m'a toujours suivi dans ma vie et
aujourd'hui j'ai eu content de pouvoir
en parler avec vous alors là j'ai un
autre produit qui a priori d'un produit
room soit si vous connaissez mèze audio
le sait le 12 classics donc je sais pas
on va tester on verra ça c'est cool j'ai
un autre produit c'est un produit de
dodo coule pas si vous connaissez c'est
pareil un casque gaming headset on verra
voilà on verra on va tester un peu tout
ça et puis on en reparlera de l'europe à
la de plein d'autres produits parce que
ce produit des chansons d'une vf mille
je remue les antisèches xm3 est très
chère 380 euros tout le monde peut pas
s'acheter voir ce qui est des internes
hâtive un peu moins cher aussi
intéressant de voir ce que ce que vaut
cette entrée casque de sony donc voilà
donc je vous invite à faire une chose
c'est à vous abonner à rester connectés
dans dites moi ce que vous pensez de ce
casque dites moi si vous êtes vraiment
intéressé à l'audio ou fait d'acheter
des casques sans fil des casques à
réduction de bruit vu marquer tout ça
bien évidemment on reste connectés et
merci à vous d'être toujours plus
nombreuses toujours plus nombreux
il ya très bientôt d'ici là gros mec
avec tchao
[Musique]
où